this is a quarter mile down you will
hear things
how many people died here I am feeling a
cold chill going up my leg
I mean I'm not gonna lie it was kind of
nice okay
we are paranormal investigator we're
gonna figure out what's here and what we
can do about it watch as our team of
experts crisscross America through the
unknown and Beyond
[Music]
I got to come out twice for being gay
and for talking to dead people I have
been a tarot card reader for 31 years
you've got Miss Alex the tech Guru
Logan's one of the best mediums I've
ever seen Ross is our researcher Juju is
our resident witch this is a pretty
simple seance
we might be dealing with something
demonic there was something hovering
over me at least moving we are not here
to provoke Spirits is everybody up here
with us
don't move
I hear gay people
you'd believe this place is haunted
employees are quitting because of the
fear of this building
the clowns aren't really bothering me
it's the bed spread that I find horrific
[Music]
this is the most important Mission we've
had yeah if your Sixth Sense is telling
you to turn around turn around these
things are not permanent and you're
worthy of a good life
thank you for trusting us you guys are
amazing I don't know what else to say
there's reports of voices I hear get out
apparitions there's someone sitting in
the chair until I was like laughter
[Music]
it's all fun and games till someone gets
possessed
we're not just here to give voices to
those who are no longer with us we're
here to make the lives of people who are
experiencing it better
you're the one who wanted to feel a
spirit you got your wish baby I did say
I wanted to feel something from a man
while in Vegas I guess that's what I got
[Music]